[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen einen
Blechkuchen mit einer Süßigkeit die ich
so unendlich liebe und zwar ist es
[Applaus]
als Kind diese Regel die Wand die haben
glaube ich 89 Pfennig gekostet diese
Regelung das kam mir so unendlich teuer
vor Fastnacht und deswegen haben wir uns
so selten gegönnt und wenn wir das dann
machen ich habe es richtig genossen auf
jeden Fall machen wir heute einen extrem
leckeren Blechkuchen von deinem
inspiriert und mit deinem und ähm ja ich
würde mal sagen let's go so für den Teig
nehmen wir uns jetzt unsere Eier falls
euch fragt wo stehen die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben die steht immer unten in
der Infobox da kommt Zucker mit rein und
Salz einfach nur so eine gute Prise die
unterstreicht noch mal den süßen
Geschmack und das ganze jetzt zwei bis
drei Minuten lang richtig schön
aufschlagen
[Musik]
das nenne ich mal eine fluffige Masse
wahnsinn das ist nur Eier und Zucker
sind so da kommt jetzt die verlassene
Butter rein habe ich in der Mikrowelle
bei geringerer Zahlen geschmolzen und
die Butter nur ganz kurz einrühren und
danach gebe ich auch schon die trockenen
Zutaten mit dazu also Mehl Backkakao und
Backpulver und sieht das auch noch mit
rein
[Musik]
so der Teig ist fertig der ist ein
bisschen klebriger als man ihn von so
einem Biskuitteig jetzt kennen würde das
ist auch ganz normal und das ist gewollt
der wird nach dem Backen total saftig
und wir trinken den dann auch noch mal
mit Milch und ich werde jetzt hier
erstmal mein Backrahmen vorbereiten das
ist super spannend übrigens also ich
sitze immer einfach so zusammen und gibt
dann so in die Ecke meines Schrankes und
der den stelle ich ein auch es müssen 24
x 26 cm sein ich habe eine
Umrechnungstabelle auf meiner Webseite
und wenn ihr da irgendwie andere Maße
habt dann könnt ihr euch das Rezept ganz
einfach umwandeln werde ich euch meine
Infobox verlinken
[Musik]
so bei 180 Grad Ober und Unterhitze
konnte mein Kuchen jetzt 12 Minuten
backen mehr braucht ihr nicht ich habe
auch extra kein Super hohen Boden weil
ich wollte den Boden Creme Anteil
richtig schön gleichmäßig und angenehm
haben und ich habe jetzt den Zahnstocher
nicht steche hier schon fleißig in den
Teig damit sich die Milch gleich den Weg
durch diese Löcher suchen kann die Milch
ist bei mir kalt und der Boden kommt
ganz frisch aus dem Ofen und dann trinkt
ihr den Boden und danach kann er
vollständig auskühlen
[Musik]
so die Creme ist sehr sehr einfach
zubereitet wir nehmen uns jetzt eine
Mascarpone habe ich schon gesagt
stehen auf jeden Fall schreibe ich immer
so auf dass ihr euch die Infobox quasi
screenshotten könnt dann könnt ihr
einkaufen gehen und das Rezept
nachmachen und dann sind die Videos auch
nicht so lange artig wenn ihr das feiert
lass mir meinen Kommentar da oder wenn
ihr generell irgendwie Vorschläge habt
dann schreibt mir auf jeden Fall einen
Kommentar heute geht es ja in Richtung
deinen und vielleicht kann es am
nächsten Mal ähm ein anderes Süßigkeit
sein also ich bin immer für Vorschläge
offen ich gebe jetzt hier noch Zucker
mit rein Schmand war das davor und da
kommt jetzt noch das mache ich
tatsächlich eigentlich nur für die Farbe
weil die Optik steht ja auch eine Rolle
das Auge ist mit ein bisschen Backkakao
das machen gar nicht so viel mit dem
Geschmack ich sieht das jetzt einfach
zur Sicherheit und so wird die Creme
einfach so ein bisschen eingefärbt und
sieht so ein bisschen schön aus ich will
jetzt nicht ganz weiß haben so und dann
nimmt ihr euch alle Karamellsoße eurer
wahrlichen natürlich meine trilette Soße
und gibt das auch noch mit dazu so
schneebesenaufsatz dran eigentlich
braucht ihr dafür tatsächlich jetzt
keine Maschine denn das wird nur so kurz
die notwendig untergerührt ich bin heute
ein bisschen faul und sobald es rührt
gebe ich Sahnefest dazu ist zwar keine
Sahne drin hilft aber das unsere Creme
einfach auf dem Kuchen schön fest wird
und sitzt genau das ganze wie gesagt
noch ein paar Sekunden verrühren bis ich
alles verbindet
[Musik]
die Creme verteile ich jetzt hier auf
dem abgekühlten Boden wichtig ist wie
gesagt dass sie diese Creme einfach nur
ein paar Sekunden verrührt je länger ihr
rührt umso flüssiger wird dass das tut
der Mascarpone nämlich nicht gut dadurch
dass wir auch keine Sahne haben die dann
irgendwie währenddessen steif wird dann
ist es wichtig dass das nur ganz kurz
verrührt wird so und das gebe ich jetzt
hier einmal wie gesagt auf dem Boden
streicht das noch mal schön glatt und
dann gehen wir auch schon über zum Guss
[Musik]
so für den Guss brauchen wir nur drei
Zutaten und zwar einmal
Vollmilchkuvertüre dann natürlich dein
ach das riecht so gut und Sahne ganz
normale Schlagsahne und ich habe jetzt
erstmal klein nicht vermischen also wir
brauchen Kuvertüre getrennt und die
diams getrennt also erstmal nur die
Kuvertüre fein hacken oder machen wir
daraus eine Ganache dadurch dass die
Sahne dazu gibt wird der Guss richtig
schön soft dann könnte der richtig gut
durchschneiden ich liebe das genau das
ganze machen wir gleich am Herd
[Musik]
so beim Guss gibt es nur eine Regel ihr
dürft die Sahne nicht aufkochen lassen
also wirklich nur erwärmen sonst
funktioniert der Guss nämlich nicht mehr
das gebe ich jetzt zum Abkühlen für 5
Minuten an die Seite nutzen Zwischenzeit
und hat hier schon mal meinen deinem
fein das gibt dann nämlich später noch
mal so einen schönen Crunch das gibt dir
dann ganz zum Schluss noch mal in die
Ganache und dann kommt es auf unserem
Kuchenboden nee auf den Kuchen Creme
Konstanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Kuchen vom Backblech runtergenommen
auf mein eckiges cakeboard und dann
einfach den Guss oben drüber verteilt es
ist so pflegeleicht sag mal dass du so
einfaches Rezept nein auf jeden Fall ist
es ein sehr sehr einfaches Rezept das
ist Anfänger geeignet das einzige was
jetzt haben müsste ein bisschen Geduld
so 3 Stunden würde ich schon empfehlen
dass er das Ganze einmal richtig sitzen
lassen die zwischen Creme wird schön
fest der Guss wird angenehm fest und
dann können wir das einfach nur noch vom
lösen und genießen und ich brauche auf
jeden Fall den haben wir gleich zum
Testen aber ich würde sagen wir sehen
uns morgen erst wieder also bis morgen
[Musik]
ich habe den allerdings schon gestern
ich weiß nicht der schmeckt aber für die
Kamera für youtube habe
deswegen wirklich extrem gut gezogen
saftig dadurch wurde mega lecker Leute
nachmachen unbedingt allgemein diese
Blechkuchen gemacht die sind immer
lecker wirklich
lecker danke schön
tschüss
könnt ihr euch
[Musik]